now this week the prime ministers told
schools in england to end the wearing
face mask some teaching unions and heads
are pretty cross about that this they
think it's premature um
where do you stand who's right
look i think i when i came into post in
march april i did a survey of england's
children and we got over half a million
responses the largest survey of children
in england done four to
eighteen-year-olds from every part of
the country and do you know what
children told me they told me they
wanted to get back to school they wanted
to deal with their mental health mental
well-being issues they wanted to catch
up um and they really and the reason
they wanted to do this was their great
ambition for their own futures they want
great jobs great careers and to create
families of their own um i have been
down so from that i wanted to put
children at the heart of recovery from
the pandemic now i've been at the school
gates and talking to colleagues and what
children are telling me is masks or not
masks we want to be back at school it's
great to be back great to be together
great to be doing extracurricular things
now my worry is the large number of
children who are not back and that's
what we should be focusing on now i have
to come to that if i may in a second but
do you think that the
lifting of the mask mandate
is going to help in that aim that you
set out or not
so i think um
we focused a lot on masks but and and i
think a lot of children find it very
hard to wear a mask all day some are
anxious and want to wear them i actually
think the key thing is that they want to
be back at school and we should be
looking at attendance because if you're
not at school you can't learn and you
can't recover
all right well look the um the signs are
that we are moving from pandemic to
endemic so
in some way we're moving to that new
normal cycle lockdowns is over
um but
you've been saying that the price that
children have had to pay is very high
and you're now
looking at this
this problem of children going off the
radar i mean um
what what what is the cause of that and
what's the scale of it
yeah so i think the scale is huge
normally normally around this time 95 of
children would be in school looking at
the figures last week
it was 87
that's you know with about 8.9 million
children in england that's a huge amount
of children now what children are
telling me is that that some of them are
not in for mental health concerns
they're not getting those met quickly
enough and the treatment they need
for some special educational needs for
some it's truancy but there's another
group as well um and that group are not
even on rolls um i was in a police
county um
recently and they showed me they had a
list of children that they've come
across who are not on anyone's roles so
what i've done is called ten
i've got data gathering powers and the
first thing i've done is called 10 local
authorities together and asked them some
basic questions i did an initial data
sweep and ask them simply how many
children have you got in your area how
many are not at school how many are
waiting for school places and they could
not all answer those questions
so i've now written to all 141 local
authority and
authorities i'm working with dfe and
with schools um for me
we need to do a number of things we need
to sort out the data and make sure that
the management information is coming
right through and we can help with that
and i'm pushing um i'm working with
local authorities and pushing at the
department for education to do something
about that it's 2022 our data systems
can deal with that but also we need to
be listening to children and i'm going
to make sure in those 10 areas and
across the country we really get to the
bottom of what children need to get back
to school so they can thrive
okay before
we and i do want to pick up the point
that you raised about children's mental
health
to what extent do you think this is
merely a dip
um a problem
about the changed circumstances we've
been living in for the next uh last two
years i beg your pardon from which we'll
recover and to what extent do you think
something
fundamental has changed that will affect
this cohort of school children
so before i did my survey i would have
gone with your former view um you know
it's been a difficult time it's it's a
well-being issue and if we get everyone
back it'll be fine but but the response
to um the big ass survey was
overwhelming um it was the number one
issue that children are telling me that
they need to thrive and that's right
across the country we got responses from
every single local authority area and
the number one issue was mental health
and mental wellbeing and so i i think
it's extremely serious and we need to
really make sure that that children are
getting the treatment they need and i've
been talking to such a javid and getting
and looking at the nhs plans to deal
with children's mental health i think i
think it really is very serious indeed